good morning believe nation today's
message is surround yourself with
greatness over to you Kevin Hart
everybody's successful lays a blue for
now you laid a blueprint out uh you know
I can go down a list from comedians to
actors to entrepreneurs to self-made
moguls you look at Russell Simmons you
look at jay-z you look at Tyler Perry
you look at puff I mean you're looking
at people to start off with a small
vision and that vision manifested in
something beyond expectation so what I
did was from the people around me my
mentors Eddie Murphy Chris Rock Pryor
who are all on the wall all in walls so
you surround yourself with somewhere I
surround myself with a constant reminder
of who is great constantly I come down
these steps every day I look at Richard
go he's great I see Eddie he was great I
see Chris Rock he was great it's a
constant reminder what am I trying to
achieve I want to be great
so that motivates me so what thinking
separates me is my drive my drive
there's other people's success I've said
this over and over and over on my
channel if you want to do great things
you need to be surrounded by greatness
in my new office now if you look on the
wall every day when I walk in I see a
picture of my parents I see a picture of
Steve Jobs I see a picture of AP
Giannini in a picture of Howard Schultz
in a picture of Kanye West and these
guys is people that I looked up to for
different things that I pulled to
inspire me to want to go and do great
things just like Kevin Hart does with
the communities that he has on his wall
it's the it's the reason why I have this
channel to surround myself with famous
entrepreneurs and people who've done a
lot more than I have so that a little
bit of their knowledge and mindset and
attitude and belief seep into me to make
me want to do greater things a quick
story for you I was driving with my dad
he had to go pick up a new car we had
this 45-minute drive to to get this new
car at that time I just signed a deal
with sage I was doing a one-on-one
hanging out with Stephen Kelly their CEO
he was a 15000 person companies on the
stock exchange and is regarded as a
leader in the community and Here I am
his equal on this channel and I'm giving
him advice offline on what he can do
better and what sage can do better and
we're answering questions together and
my dad asked me what gave you the
confidence to tell him what to do and
give him advice and feel like you're an
equal in answering questions and he was
asking more out of not like who are you
to do this but more out of amazement and
unhappiness and it's only because I
firmly believe that I watched these
videos every day like I am surrounded by
great entrepreneurs and people doing
amazing things every single day and if
you do that consistently that mindset
that bigger thinking that confidence
can't help but seep in the changing in
your mindsets and limiting beliefs can't
help but seep in and make you grow and
so because I'm surrounded by all of
these people I've maybe never met but I
see them every day and their voices are
in my head that gives me the confidence
to want to do great things and if you
look at your environment the people you
hang out with the books you read the
videos you watch music you listen to you
know what you do on your downtime you
look at all of this stuff you look at
everything around you look at the
physical space and what's on the walls
and on the floors and what the room
smells like at everything your
environment is holding you where you are
and until you change your environment to
be one that is great you won't do great
things yourself so start to make that
change if you want to do great things we
need to be surrounded by greatness so
the question today today is I'm curious
what you've done with your physical
space to surround yourself with
greatness what have you put up on the
walls or what do you listen to I'm
really curious to find out leave in the
comments below and I will join the
discussion thank you so much for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe and I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot events best way
let's pray so give me go